question what the [ __ ] happened to Bella
Thorne honestly I don't know I think
that every day I literally look in the
mirror and I'm like yo what the [ __ ]
happened evil it's a I'm Bella Thorne
also known as you expert and I'm
throwing my trolls level of
procrastination I spent 30 minutes
creeping bellhorn's Twitter and I don't
even know darn it hey hey good for me
though you literally spent you wasted 30
minutes of your day to literally look at
my life
its goals right there how many retweets
for you to go to prom with me
oh then yeah it depends I got a book it
out my schedule I got films and like
they're really dicks about me booking
out dates so I don't know that that's
going to happen good morning everyone
except Bella Thorne that's funny yeah
that's really buddy I can't even drill
you because your trolling yourself man I
want to beat Bella Thorne's ass in all
seriousness you could like give it a
good slap that really turns me on like
I'm really down for that Bella looks
extremely good with blonde and ginger
hair any other color doesn't suit her
Wow
we just like ruled out every single
color in the whole universe and you've
only seen me with like green and rainbow
you know what I say to you guys
you're just you're boring if you don't
like colored hair I want Bella born to
punch me in the face it would just make
my day okay you literally want me to
punch her in the face like is just Mean
Girls one time she punched me in the
face it was awesome Wow why did I have a
dream that Nick and Belfour had made a
porno together which meant is there a
girl involved is it a threesome cuz like
I'm down where are her piercings we have
to go over this again everybody knows
where they're at come on why are you
even asking is it me or does the 80s
singer Tiffany look a bit like belt okay
everybody tells me that
that's dope thank you I want to fight
Bella Thorne come at me bro
I never thought Bella Thorne would grow
on me as an FC but now that I have her
on snapchat I don't hate her anymore
she seems chill that's [ __ ] dope thank
you I don't know what FC means get out
of here you're not even out on urban
dictionary but yeh oh hold on fellas
corners on my TV can she leave me alone
ha [ __ ] I'm everywhere you can't
escape me my message for my trolls I
guess is like look you guys you can't
get rid of me
[Music]
Oh